two percent of kindergarten teachers in
America are male some insanely small
proportions yes it's about two percent
it's not going up either very low number
and to put it in perspective as a share
of the profession there are twice as
many flying U.S military planes as there
are men teaching kindergarten and so
isn't even seen as a problem to be
addressed why would it matter to have
male teachers in schools there's two big
reasons one is because the evidence
suggests that when there are male
teachers in schools especially in
subjects like English or even in early
years the boys seem to do a bit better
and in the early years there's some
evidence that a bigger mix will be good
for boys in the long run but the other
reason I think is that if we're trying
to change gender stereotypes there's a
nice line for the women's movement which
is you have to see it to be it if boys
don't see any men in any of those roles
then it's not surprising that it's tough
to get men to think about changing their
lives so that they feel more of those
roles with Gloria Steinem said that the
idea we get about what it means to male
and female comes in our earliest years